it's time for a clash of the titans  scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile  scp-106 the old man and scp-953 the  polymorphic humanoid this wasn't even a  foundation cross test just an organic  battle that occurred during a massive  containment breach scp-953 and scp-106  entered 682's containment chamber at  which point they all began staring at  each other preparing for an attack 106  began the battle sinking into the floor  and grabbing 953 trying to pull her into  his pocket dimension she then grabbed  682 resulting in all three of them being  pulled into the pocket dimension they  all remained there for five hours before  returning heavily injured from their  fight 106 returned to his chamber 953  was recaptured by foundation personnel  and 682 regenerated its 67 body mass  loss all three have refused to speak  about the incident since